♪ ♪
>> Jason: PRESIDENT TRUMP
CAMPAIGNED ON ABOUT TO GIVE
AMERICA FROM GETTING TOO
INVOLVED IN FOREIGN
ENTANGLEMENTS.
NOW HE WANTS TO MAKE GOOD ON
THAT PROMISE IN SYRIA.
>> I WANT TO GET OUT.
I WANT TO BRING OUR TROOPS BACK
HOME.
I WANT TO START REBUILDING OUR
NATION.
WE WILL HAVE, AS OF THREE MONTHS
AGO, $7 TRILLION IN THE
MIDDLE EAST OVER THE LAST 17
YEARS.
WE GET NOTHING, NOTHING OUT OF
IT.
>> Jason: A NUMBER OF MILITARY
ANALYSTS WORRY THAT WOULD CREATE
A VACUUM AND REPEAT THE SAME
MISTAKES THEY SAY
PRESIDENT OBAMA MADE IN IRAQ.
LET'S DISCUSS THAT WITH FORMER
GREEN BERET AND CONGRESSIONAL
CANDIDATE MICHAEL WALTON FORMER
ARMY ARMY MILITARY POLICE
SERGEANT CHRIS AND    .
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
I WANT TO KNOW THAT MICHAEL WALT
WAS A FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR BUT
NOW HE IS A CANDIDATE FOR
CONGRESS, HE'S NOT BUT HE STILL
JOINING US TONIGHT.
CHRIS, I WANT TO START WITH YOU.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT'S HEART IS
IN THE RIGHT PLACE.
IS IT A SMART MOVE TO TELEGRAPH
TO THE ENEMY THAT WE WILL BRING
OUR TROOPS OUT?
>> JASON, I DON'T THINK HE IS
TELEGRAPHING.
I THINK IT'S A JOB, HE IS
THROWING TO THROW OUT A TRIAL.
CERTAINLY THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T
THINK WE SHOULD BE SPENDING
ENDLESSLY OVER THERE.
I THINK THAT MANY OF THE
EXPERTS, MANY OF WHICH I
RESPECT, THEY DIDN'T GET IT ON
THE POST WAR IRAQ RIGHT, SO THE
PRESIDENT DOESN'T WANT US TO BE
ENDLESSLY THERE.
WE'VE KNOCKED OUT OVER 80, 90%
OF ISIS, SO HE'S TRYING TO
REBALANCE AND GET OUR ALLIES TO
PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE AS WELL.
>> Jason: IS THE PRESIDENT
DOING THE RIGHT THING?
WILL HE BRING ALL THE TROOPS
HOME NOW?
>> I THINK YOU PUT IT WELL.
HIS HEART IS IN THE RIGHT PLACE
IN TERMS OF LET'S FINISH THIS
THING AND GET TO THE SOLDIERS
HOME.
THREE THINGS ARE GOING TO HAPPEN
IF WE PULL OUT NOW.
IT'S TOO SOON.
THE PRESIDENT WAS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT TO TAKE THE RESTRICTIVE --
FOCUS ON ANNIHILATING ISIS.
IF WE PULL OUT NOW, ONE, WE WILL
SEE ISIS THREE-POINT OH.
THE SAME CONDITIONS THAT ARE
THERE THAT LEAD TO ISIS FROM
AL QAEDA WILL LEAD TO ISIS
THREE-POINT OH.
NUMBER TWO, OUR ALLIES THAT WE
HAVE BEEN SO RELIANT ON ON THE
GROUND, THAT HAVE ALLOWED US TO
ONLY HAVE 2,000 TROOPS ON THE
GROUND, THE KURDS AND THE ARABS,
WILL GET ANNIHILATED.
IF WE DO HAVE ISIS RECONSTITUTE
AND START A ATTACKING EUROPE IN
THE UNITED STATES AGAIN, IT WILL
HAVE A HECK OF A TIME GETTING
THEM TO TRUST US.
THREE, WE'LL ESSENTIALLY ABANDON
THE REGION TO IRAN.
>> Jason: BUT MICHAEL, THAT
WOULD GO ON IN PERPETUITY.
TO MEET THOSE CONDITIONS, WILL
WE BE THERE FOREVER?
>> WE'VE BEEN IN GERMANY, WE'VE
BEEN IN JAPAN, WE'VE BEEN IN
SOUTH KOREA, WE STILL HAVE
25,000 TROOPS IN JAPAN.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS PRESIDENT,
LIKE WITH SOUTH KOREA, IS GOING
TO HAVE TO CLEAN UP THE MESSES
THAT OBAMA LEFT HIM AFTER EIGHT
YEARS OF ESSENTIALLY TURNING HIS
BACK COMPLETELY ON THE REGION
AND IT'S GOING TO TAKE LONGER.
IT'S JUST TOO SOON AT THIS
POINT.
HE IS RIGHT, AND GETTING OUR
ALLIES TO PAY UP AND TO PONY UP
AND WE OUGHT TO LOOK AT WHAT
BUSH 41 DEAD IN THE FIRST
GULF WAR, WHERE YOU HAD GERMANY,
JAPAN, AND THE GOLF ALLIES
CONTRIBUTING --
>> Jason: THE PRESIDENT HAS
DONE HUGE WORK TO GET THE ALLIES
TO PAY FOR NATO.
>> HE ABSOLUTELY SHOULD DO THIS.
>> Jason: CHRIS, UNDER WHAT
CONDITIONS, WHEN DO YOU BRING
THE TROOPS HOME?
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN OVERNIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT IS SIGNALING HE
WANTS TO SEE MORE SUPPORT FROM
THOSE IN THE REGION.
IT'S TOUGH WORK.
MANY OF THOSE WHO SERVED IN IRAQ
AND AFGHANISTAN LOST LIVES,
LEGS, FIGHTING WARS WHERE THE
POSTWAR RECONSTRUCTION ORDER DID
NOT WORK.
HE IS HOLDING UP ASSETS IN
SYRIA.
I THINK ULTIMATELY THE PRESIDENT
WILL GALVANIZE OTHER SUPPORTERS
TO COME TO THE TABLE.
IT'S A CHESS MATCH.
I THINK HE IS SMART AND SOME OF
OUR SENIOR ADVISORS DON'T GIVE
HIM THE CREDIT HE DESERVES.
IT'S CHESS.
WE'VE GOT TO GET OTHER ALLIES, I
THINK MR. BALTIMORE WILL HAVE
THE PRESIDENT'S EAR.
WE'LL HAVE A GOOD PLAN GOING
FORWARD.
WE CAN'T ENDLESSLY PAY AND DO
ALL OF THE WORK OURSELVES
WITHOUT HAVING OTHERS HELP US
OUT.
IT WON'T BE LIKE IRAQ.
THE PRESIDENT IS SENDING THOSE
EXPECTATIONS.
>> Jason: MICHAEL, IT SHOULD
BE A SIMPLE QUESTION BUT I THINK
IT IS ONE OF THE MOST DIFFICULT
QUESTIONS.
WHAT IS VICTORY?
WHAT IS VICTORY IN AFGHANISTAN
AND WHAT IS VICTORY IN SYRIA AND
DEALING WITH ISIS?
>> JASON, THAT IS A BROADER